Lock young to this video playing wargasm
from from Sweden I know the flag just
that just some bloke Katie okay this is
interesting if he goes yes people simply
do they look at theory nowadays this is
an interesting line at the moment quite
dangerous for the white yeah I don't
take on the seventh this is this is
really a bit dangerous I can't show you
afterwards some some detail about this
this line okay just play conservatively
attacking the center okay can I do 92
here d 4 95 or is this an awkward self
pin yeah it is an awkward self in but it
is it bad or not
yeah still and the only move that
somehow make sense of my my earlier play
threatening Knight f6 so after 95 I
don't think he has some easy refutation
maybe Bishop g5 actually hmm no is going
all the way back
there's also night a five
okay this was probably not a very good
idea however however is there is there
some way to operate with this Queen with
this Queen takes b7 idea yes he has
Knight a5 versus is totally totally
annoying hmm
and 97 now and this was really stupid
why did I go for this in the first place
I really have no no way to save this
even if or you can just take it and play
Knight a5 afterwards
my can i after 97 I have no move I mean
just like that oh it does not take it
maybe he feels like he can take it
whenever he he wants but really can I
not play this now keeping my material
does not look very ammonius but still
yeah what's very important is always
play instantly show that you can
calculate in thousands of a second but
not take the piece that I basically
blundered strange stuff so I can play
not that cannot play night before him
unfortunately it's still an awkward
awkward pin by this bishop now
yeah b6 i can i can take here Roxy six
now night c4 is this no one idea is not
fattening this evil even it4s a move
yeah why not why not Bishop age 69 f six
wins the Queen and I really don't see
what he's doing now Bishop takes rook
takes is also good for white 2596 again
winning the Queen yeah here I cannot I
cannot take I can take here i take c 6
time warning
retreating it is not I can do that
actually the bishop is hanging on on g 5
i'm down to 47 seconds this is a more
serious problem
hmm Joe 47 but at least he is taking
some time now as well that's helpful
right I don't see a great move but I
overlooked many as many things already
in this game okay you can teach at Queen
B 5 rock the eighth and I can take you
five next now night g files are is a
move possibly might have six Roxy one
that's very nice this threatening Knight
f6 not now this this is also an
interesting move Bishop g2
non-threatening rook c6 another check
okay I'm not threatening it but I'm
close 25 seconds
that's the problem check this rook c7
idea check check check meydan c8
Lucas is seven is coming Jeff
check check check yeah yeah i just spent
far too much time at the beginning for
its when I lost then he screwed it up
totally and I didn't have any time left
to to punish that yeah in any way of
course the deserved loss as I'm totally
losing after the opening he just refuse
refuse to take pieces and don't know why
95 wins apiece I had no way to defend
that castles is just I don't know just
no words the better keep quiet okay look
at the eighth and now he's starting to
to be worse check this he just blundered
and now white is just winning but i only
have 40 seconds so this is this is
tricky and brooke see 196 chance i can
yeah this is this is this is what I
should have done actually this is the
easiest with the winning end game as in
fact quite easily winning because I have
this idea to advance with the king and
have the C file it is pretty simple to
play even yeah this is also very good
but okay it's a it's a time a time
problems of course 20 seconds is a bit
little check check guarantee own books
seven or whatever its you cannot come
you cannot complete the game here with
16 seconds it's just just a too little
time but okay well he could have won
easily in the opening this line um I
really should stop playing because
people um I mean this always had the
reputation to be better for white as
black players kept going Queen B 6 cm or
other moves that are even worse Quincy 8
or something for example but now people
have recognized that this is in fact the
very dangerous gambit it looks a bit
strange because black is playing the
bishop 2 times but here black gets in a
quickie 5 and the Queen loses enormous
time and this is not something that wide
really want so I gambled a bit but
people keep keep catching up on that and
therefore this queen bee three is not
really a good line anymore at least it's
not very tempting and blitz as you can
probably don't want to take all right
free bad game thanks for watching